William is part of a team that's rebuilding one of the power plants outside Baghdad. And for everything that you've probably heard about how dangerous it is to be in Iraq, and how difficult much of the work is, here's one occupational hazard you probably haven't heard of.
威廉所在的团队正在重建巴格达郊外的一座发电厂。关于你可能听说过伊拉克局势有多危险、工作有多困难的种种传言，这里有一个你可能没听说过的职业隐患。
Working seven days a week, it's very easy to lose track of the time. There's no difference in a Monday, or a Friday, or a Sunday. It's all the same day.
每周工作七天，很容易就会失去对时间的感知。星期一、星期五或星期日根本没区别。每一天都一样。
Well, we jokingly refer to it as a groundhog day.
嗯，我们开玩笑说这就是“土拨鼠日”（日复一日的轮回）。
Jerry's training Iraqi police.
杰瑞正在训练伊拉克警察。
Because you're not sure what day it is. And when you come right down to it, it's not much different than yesterday. And it's going to be the same as tomorrow. Visits to the Green Zone, some business in the palace, some business at the police stations.
因为你根本不知道今天是星期几。仔细想想，今天和昨天没多大区别。明天也会和今天一样。去绿区看看，处理些宫殿里的事务，再处理些警察局的事务。
Don works out at the airport for a private security firm. He says everybody loses track of time.
唐在机场为一家私人安保公司工作。他说每个人都会失去时间感。
We had a guy in a vehicle that hit a landmine. And miraculously, nobody got hurt. And when they brought him to the doctor, the doctor asked, what day is it? I can't tell you what day it is most days, and I haven't been hit by a landmine. That was kind of an unfair question.
我们有个伙计开的车撞上了地雷。奇迹般的是，没人受伤。当他们把他带去见医生时，医生问：“今天是星期几？”大多数时候我也不知道今天是星期几，而且我还没被地雷炸过。这问题确实有点不公平。
Today's radio show came from a simple set of questions. We keep hearing about these private contractors who are working in Iraq. These are civilians, doing everything for US troops from serving meals and building housing to maintaining weapons systems. Private contractors interrogated prisoners at Abu Ghraib prison. Other contractors are the people who are actually rebuilding Iraq's sewage, and water, and electrical infrastructure.
今天的广播节目源于一系列简单的问题。我们不断听说这些在伊拉克工作的私人承包商。他们是平民，为美军做着从供应餐食、建造住房到维护武器系统的所有工作。私人承包商在阿布格莱布监狱审讯囚犯。其他承包商则是实际重建伊拉克下水道、供水和电力基础设施的人。
And here at our radio show we wondered, who are these people who signed up for this, who decided that the very best job that they could get was going to be in the middle of a war zone? Should we just see them as mercenaries? Are they motivated by feelings that are more idealistic than that?
在我们电台，我们感到好奇：这些报名参加这项工作的人是谁？是谁决定了他们能找到的最好工作就是在战区中心？我们应该把他们仅仅看作雇佣兵吗？还是说他们的动机比那更理想化？
Civilians are part of this war in unprecedented numbers. They're an important part of the war effort. They're part of what is going to determine if we're successful in Iraq or not. Nobody knows for sure, but it is at least 20,000 people in Iraq, working just as soldiers-for-hire, escorting convoys, protecting stuff. That's more than any of the countries in the Coalition of the Willing have sent. Britain, who sent the most, only sent 9,000 troops.
平民以空前的规模参与了这场战争。他们是战争努力的重要组成部分。他们是决定我们在伊拉克是否成功的因素之一。没人知道确切数字，但在伊拉克至少有两万人，他们就像雇佣兵一样工作，负责护送车队、保护物资。这比“意志联盟”中任何一个国家派出的兵力都多。英国派遣的兵力最多，也才九千人。
Private contractors, in a sense, are our biggest allies in Iraq, the coalition partners that nobody ever talks about, partly because they're private companies, who don't usually give access to reporters, under no obligation to give access. As a result, we don't even know how many of their employees have died. There's a website called icasualties.org, which lists 243 confirmed deaths, actual names. This is far more casualties than all of our allies combined.
从某种意义上说，私人承包商是我们在这个国家最大的盟友，是没人谈论的联盟伙伴，部分原因是他们是私人公司，通常不对记者开放，也没有义务提供采访。结果，我们甚至不知道有多少员工已经丧生。有一个名为 icasualties.org 的网站，列出了243名确认死亡者的真实姓名。这比我们所有盟友的总和伤亡人数还要多得多。
About a year ago, April 2004-- this is right at the moment when the violence in Iraq was really heating up-- one of our contributing editors, Nancy Updike, headed into Iraq, and managed to spend three weeks with employees of several different companies who are operating there. We're devoting our entire program today to her report.
大约一年前，即2004年4月——就在伊拉克暴力冲突真正升级的时候——我们的一位特约编辑南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）前往伊拉克，设法与在那里的几家不同公司的员工共同度过了三周。我们今天整个节目都将用于报道她的见闻。
From Chicago Public Radio, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. And we start at the airport.
这里是芝加哥公共广播电台的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们要从机场说起。
When Nancy was in Iraq, one of the dozens of security firms operating there was an outfit based in Rhode Island called Custer Battles, named for the two guys who started the company. Among other things, they had a contract to run security for much of Baghdad International Airport, where there are also lots of US soldiers stationed. Here's Nancy.
当南希在伊拉克时，在那里运营的几十家安保公司中，有一家总部设在罗德岛的公司叫“卡斯特-巴特尔”（Custer Battles），公司名字取自创始人的名字。除其他事项外，他们还承包了巴格达国际机场大部分的安保工作，那里也驻扎着许多美军士兵。下面由南希带来报道。
The US military and the private security contractors working in Iraq, who are often ex-military themselves, usually get along. But not always. I was driving around Baghdad International Airport on a Tuesday afternoon with Dave Shoe, a six foot four, former middle school social studies teacher, former Army Sergeant, current employee of Custer Battles, when he pulled up next to two guys jogging in gray t-shirts that said, ARMY.
美军和在伊拉克工作的私人安保承包商（他们往往也是退伍军人）通常能相处得来。但并非总是如此。一个周二下午，我正坐着戴夫·舒（Dave Shoe）的车在巴格达国际机场周围行驶。他身高六英尺四英寸，曾是初中社会学老师，也是退役陆军中士，现在是卡斯特-巴特尔的员工。当时他把车停在两个穿着灰色体恤的慢跑者旁边，T恤上写着“陆军”字样。
Hey, guys. Got a minute? You're not supposed to be running back here, fellas.
嘿，伙计们。有一分钟吗？你们不该在这里跑步，伙计们。
Says who?
谁说的？
Well, number one, says me, OK?
嗯，第一，我说的，行吗？
You're not even my boss.
你又不是我的老板。
Well--
嗯——
My boss is Major General Dempsey, who's in charge of the five million people that are in the city of Baghdad, you included.
我的老板是登普西少将，他负责巴格达市五百万人的安全，包括你在内。
Well, Major Dempsey then--
嗯，那么登普西少将——
Major General Dempsey.
是登普西少将。
Well, Major General Dempsey, then, is the one who informed us. And a matter of fact, MOTC, ministry of transportation--
嗯，那么是登普西少将通知我们的。而且事实上，交通部（MOTC）——
Well, [BEEP] the ministry of transportation.
得了吧，[消音]交通部。
OK.
好吧。
Dave climbed down from his truck, and this became a 10-minute argument, complete with finger pointing, getting in each other's faces, almost touching chests. There are tens of thousands of US soldiers living on the airport grounds, which are huge, 11 square miles. And many of them don't realize that even though the airport is used by military helicopters and planes, it's also a civilian airport, guarded in part by a civilian company. And some areas are off-limits, even to US soldiers.
戴夫从卡车上爬下来，这演变成了一场长达10分钟的争论，伴随着指指点点、脸贴着脸，胸口几乎都要撞到一起。在机场区域居住着数万名美军士兵，这片区域非常巨大，有11平方英里。他们中许多人并没有意识到，尽管机场被军用直升机和飞机使用，但它同时也是一个民用机场，部分由一家民营公司负责安保。即使对于美军士兵来说，有些区域也是禁区。
So Dave spends a lot of time kicking people out of places. Very few respond graciously.
所以戴夫花了很多时间把人从这些地方赶走。很少有人会客气地配合。
Number one, I ain't in your army, OK?
第一，我不在你的军队里，明白吗？
I know you're not.
我知道你不在。
Now, I came up here and said, hey, how about you doing me a favor. Now you want to make it an issue, we can make it an issue.
现在，我走过来对你说，嘿，能不能帮我个忙。如果你现在想把它变成个问题，那我们可以把它变成个问题。
OK, make it an issue! First of all--
好吧，那就把它变成个问题！首先——
Now, let me tell you something, Major. No, you let me tell you.
现在，让我告诉你一些事，少校。不，让我来告诉你。
Go ahead! Tell me!
你说吧！告诉我！
Let me tell you! I pulled up to you. I asked you politely. You got an attitude.
让我告诉你！我是开车过来找你的。我很有礼貌地问你。但你态度很差。
You're damn right I got an attitude! I've got civilians that have been here a couple months--
你说的太对了，我态度就是差！我有几个平民在这儿待了几个月了——
I've been here since freaking July, pal.
老兄，我从该死的七月就在这儿了。
Oh, whoopdedoo.
哦，真是了不起。
How long you been here?
你在这儿待了多久？
I've been here since March.
我从三月就在这儿了。
Good for you, you're doing your job! But let me tell you something. I asked you politely. Now if you got to make an issue out of it, why don't we take it on up to Mayor [? Seller. ?]
为你鼓掌，你做得很称职！但让我告诉你一些事。我是礼貌地问你的。如果你非要把这变成个问题，为什么我们不去塞勒市长（Mayor Seller）那里处理呢？
Well, right now, I'm practicing my right!
好吧，现在，我正在行使我的权利！
Right now, I'm telling you, you are unauthorized to be here. You got that?
现在，我告诉你，你未经授权在此地。你明白吗？
I got that. You're really stressing me.
我明白了。你真是让我感到压力很大。
Move out!
滚出去！
[BEEP] you!
[消音]你！
As we drove away, Dave put the incident in context.
当我们开车离开时，戴夫将这次事件置于背景中。
That's the kind of bull [BEEP] I put up with all day long. Right there.
我整天都在忍受这种废[消音]话。就是刚才那样。
Because it's not clear who controls--
因为不清楚谁控制——
No, it's clear.
不，很清楚。
--what area?
——哪个区域？
No, it's clear. That guy's an ass [BEEP].
不，很清楚。那个家伙是个屁[消音]。
So is there generally tension between you guys and army guys?
所以你们和军队的人之间通常会有紧张关系吗？
No. That guy's an ass [BEEP].
没有。那个家伙是个屁[消音]。
Of course, almost any job involves dealing with a few people you wish you could eject into deep space. But most jobs don't have, on top of that, the stress of daily shootings and bombings, and being thousands of miles from home. So I asked everyone, why come to Baghdad?
当然，几乎任何工作都涉及与一些你希望将其弹射到外太空的人打交道。但大多数工作并没有外加每日的枪击和爆炸带来的压力，也不用远离家乡数千里。所以我问每个人，为什么要来巴格达？
A couple of reasons, and I'll be honest, money is one of them.
有几个原因，老实说，金钱是其中之一。
Don Ritchie oversees Custer Battles security operations at the airport. When he retired from the military at 43, he needed to find a job.
唐·里奇（Don Ritchie）负责监督卡斯特-巴特尔在机场的安保业务。当他在43岁从军队退役时，他需要找一份工作。
19 and a half years in the military, two master's degrees, only job I could find in real American business was as a clerk at Blue Cross in South Carolina. $17,000 a year. I started as a clerk. Humbling experience, very humbling experience.
在军队服役了19年半，拥有两个硕士学位，我能找到的唯一一份真正的美国商业工作是在南卡罗来纳州的一家蓝十字保险公司当文员。一年1.7万美元。我是从文员做起的。一种令人谦卑的经历，非常令人谦卑的经历。
I would say the main reason is money. The main reason is money.
我会说主要原因就是钱。主要原因就是钱。
Adam McCall does patrols at the airport. He says he took 9/11 personally, and got himself a job for a while at the Department of Homeland Security in Washington. He still wants to make a difference, but the money is better here in Iraq.
亚当·麦考尔（Adam McCall）在机场执行巡逻任务。他说他把“9·11”事件当作个人的事，在华盛顿的国土安全部找到了一份工作。他仍然想有所作为，但在伊拉克的钱更多。
Do you have debts that you're trying to pay off?
你有需要偿还的债务吗？
Absolutely, yeah. Who doesn't? Yeah, absolutely. Welcome to America, yes. Yes, I have lots of debts. $30,000, $40,000.
绝对有，是的。谁没有呢？是的，绝对有。欢迎来到美国，没错。是的，我背负着很多债务。三万、四万美元。
That's a big chunk of change.
那是一大笔钱。
Exactly. And frankly, I wasn't making it when I was Department of Homeland Security. I just wasn't making it. So, you know, I had to come here.
确实。坦白说，我在国土安全部工作时根本存不下钱。就是存不下。所以，你知道，我不得不来这儿。
The median income in the United States, according to the Census Bureau, is a bit over $40,000 a year. In Iraq, Americans working for private companies usually start at around $80,000, tax-free. Some get more for overtime or hazardous duty. Security guys make over $100,000 a year. Again, the first $80,000 isn't taxed if they stay outside the states for 330 days. Housing and meals are free. If you can tolerate the tension, heat, long hours, uneven phone service, loneliness, sexual frustration, and fear, Baghdad can be a good place not just to make money, but also to make enough money to maybe turn your life around.
根据人口普查局的数据，美国的收入中位数略高于每年4万美元。在伊拉克，为私营公司工作的美国人起薪通常在8万美元左右，免税。有些人还能因为加班或危险任务拿到更多钱。安保人员一年收入超过10万美元。同样，如果他们待在国外的时间超过330天，前8万美元不征税。食宿全免。如果你能忍受紧张、炎热、长时间工作、不稳定的电话服务、孤独、性挫折和恐惧，巴格达不仅是一个赚钱的好地方，也是一个赚到足够的钱去改变人生的好地方。
People told me they now have savings for the first time. They'd be able to send their kids to the universities they want. Or put that divorce behind them. Henry [? Bosarge's ?] job is repairing guns for Custer Battles at the airport. He was in the military for nine years, and puts it in perspective this way, bringing up one of the biggest private companies in Iraq, KBR, Kellogg Brown & Root.
人们告诉我，他们现在第一次有了存款。他们将能够送他们的孩子去他们想去的大学。或者把离婚这件事抛在脑后。亨利·博萨奇（Henry Bosarge）的工作是在机场修理卡斯特-巴特尔的枪支。他在军队服役了九年，他这样看待这个问题，提到了伊拉克最大的私人公司之一——KBR（凯洛格·布朗及路特公司）。
A specialist who has to climb under a truck and work 12 hours a day makes $1,500 a month.
一个必须钻到卡车底下工作12小时的专业士兵，一个月赚1500美元。
In the military.
在军队里。
In the military. The same guy, working for KBR, the same guy across the street from him, is making $10,000 a month.
在军队里。同样的人，为KBR工作，就在他街对面的那个人，一个月赚1万美元。
$10,000?
1万美元？
Yeah.
是的。
How on earth are we saving money with private contractors when you guys are making so much money?
当你们这些家伙赚这么多钱的时候，我们怎么可能通过私人承包商省钱呢？
You're not. You're not.
你省不了。省不了的。
Money, the idea that private contractors will save taxpayer money, is just one reason behind the boom in hiring civilians to do these jobs. The other reason is that the military is shrinking. There were two million active duty US military personnel in 1990. Now it's 1.4 million. Private contractors are filling in the jobs that the old, bigger military used to do for itself: peeling potatoes, fixing equipment, building housing. The idea is to free up soldiers for what the Pentagon calls war-making, combat.
钱，即“私人承包商能为纳税人省钱”这个想法，只是雇佣平民来做这些工作背后原因之一。另一个原因是军队正在萎缩。1990年时有200万现役美军人员。现在是140万。私人承包商正在填补以前庞大的军队曾经自己完成的工作岗位：削土豆、修理设备、建造住房。其初衷是为了解放士兵，让他们专注于五角大楼所谓的“制造战争”，即战斗。
The line's gotten blurry, though. More and more, private contractors are hired to guard, patrol, escort people and food and equipment through dangerous places, jobs that end up putting them in combat. Military commanders have said they're afraid the vastly higher salaries in these private companies, essentially for-profit armies, will drain the military of experienced people.
然而，界限已经变得模糊了。私人承包商越来越多地被雇佣来执行守卫、巡逻、护送人员、食物和设备经过危险地区的任务，这些工作最终让他们卷入了战斗。军事指挥官们表示，他们担心这些私营公司本质上是营利性军队，其高得多的薪水会吸走军队中经验丰富的人员。
Custer Battles has different groups working in Iraq. There are the people out at the airport. And then there are guys who work out of Baghdad, PSDs, personal security details, like the guys who were killed in Fallujah. PSDs protect businessmen, military convoys, some government officials, and private contractors who've come to rebuild. Hank is the man who was brought in to clean up Custer Battles' PSD operation. It's had some problems. More on that later. Hank has a vision for the kind of men he wants working for him.
卡斯特-巴特尔在伊拉克有不同的工作组。有人在机场工作。还有些人在巴格达之外工作，即个人安保小组（PSD），就像在费卢杰被杀害的那些人一样。PSD负责保护商人、军事车队、一些政府官员和来这里重建的私人承包商。汉克（Hank）是被请来整顿卡斯特-巴特尔 PSD 行动的人。它出现了一些问题。稍后详述。汉克对在他手下工作的人员有自己的构想。
Steely-eyed, flat-bellied professionals.
眼神坚毅、腹部平坦的专业人士。
It's possible Hank came up with this description by looking in the mirror. He's a 49-year-old man with small blue eyes, a former paratrooper and ranger, the son of a decorated soldier, married to the daughter of a soldier, father of two soldiers, one of whom was in Iraq and is now in Afghanistan on a mission he can't talk about. Hank is cryptic. He doesn't want me to use his last name. He won't even tell me what rank he achieved. I looked it up later. Lieutenant colonel. He's done private security work overseas before, he won't give details, of course. But he will-- and this is the thing about Hank-- he will poke fun at it.
汉克能想出这个描述，很可能是因为他照过镜子。他是一个49岁的男人，有着一双小蓝眼睛，前伞兵和游骑兵，是一位受勋士兵的儿子，娶了一位士兵的女儿，是两名士兵的父亲，其中一个在伊拉克，现在正在阿富汗执行一项他不能谈论的任务。汉克说话很隐晦。他不想让我用他的姓氏。他甚至不告诉我他达到了什么军衔。后来我自己查了一下。中校。他以前曾在海外做过私人安保工作，当然，他不会透露细节。但他会——这就是汉克这个人——他会拿它开玩笑。
So you've got to be the look, the security guy-look: serious, I'm dead serious about this business; I'm steely-eyed, and I'm scanning the horizon constantly. And usually when you go to, like, if I go to Africa or someplace like that, and you're on some kind of security mission, it takes you about two seconds just to get off the plane, look around, and say, oh, there's somebody else on a mission.
所以你必须得是那个样子，那种安保人员的样子：严肃，我对这行非常认真；我眼神坚毅，而且我一直在扫描地平线。通常当你去，比如我去非洲或其他类似地方执行某种安保任务时，下飞机、环顾四周只需要两秒钟，然后说：“哦，还有别人也在执行任务。”
And you kind of saddle up to them and you go, SAS? And they go, they nod and then they go, rangers? And you go, you kind of nod. And then finally you ask, who you working for? Of course he can't tell. He asks you, and you can't tell. And then you-- [LAUGHTER] wander off, you see? But you had that initial, like, dogs sniffing each other, you do. But it's very easy to pick the guys out. They all got the look.
你就会凑过去说：“SAS（英国特种空勤团）？”他们会点点头，然后说：“游骑兵？”你也点点头。最后你问：“你为谁工作？”当然他不能说。他问你，你也不能说。然后你就——（笑声）走开了，你看？但你们之间有那种最初的像狗互相嗅对方的感觉，确实有。但要挑出这些人非常容易。他们都有那种样子。
So he wants his PSD guys to have to look.
所以他想让他的 PSD 手下人也有那种样子。
Steely-eyed, flat-bellied professionals.
眼神坚毅、腹部平坦的专业人士。
And he walks around doing that look, but he also knows it's all a bit of a put-on, a man dance, as he calls it. And with tens of thousands of American military and ex-military and private military in Iraq right now, it's very possible that we are standing in the middle of the largest man dance on the planet.
他走来走去摆出那副样子，但他也知道这都有点表演性质，正如他所说的，是一场“男人之舞”。而现在在伊拉克有数万名美国军人、退伍军人和私人军事人员，我们很可能正站在这个星球上最大的一场“男人之舞”的中间。
Tomorrow at 7:00, we gotta get on the range. And then we've got weapons training we'll do when we come back in the afternoon--
明天7点，我们得去靶场。下午回来后还要进行武器训练——
Hank has called a meeting of the personal security detail guys to go over the week's schedule and work out solutions to some of the problems they've been having. The meeting is in a long room off the main dining area of their hotel. The guys are sitting scattered around the room, mostly Americans, a few from other countries, England, Ireland, Nepal. They're all on year-long contracts as shooters, armed protection.
汉克召集了个人安保小组的人开会，讨论本周的日程安排，并制定解决他们一直遇到的一些问题的方案。会议在他们酒店主餐厅旁边的一个长房间里举行。队员们分散坐在房间里，大多是美国人，有几个来自其他国家，英国、爱尔兰、尼泊尔。他们都签了一年的射手/武装护卫合同。
Hank is roaming the room and occasionally clicking to change the slide on the projector. A lot of the meeting is about cars, because a lot of PSD work is just driving people safely from A to B: Baghdad to Mosul, Mosul to Basra. Safely in Iraq, by the way, means driving as fast as they can at all times, to avoid getting shot or blown up. All the security companies do this. And Custer Battles, in order to keep their security guys free to scan the road and shoot, if necessary, uses Iraqi drivers. Baghdad Bob, AKA Hustler, sees a problem with this, because it seems the Iraqis they've hired, very understandably, have been balking at some of the driving instructions they get.
汉克在房间里踱步，不时点击鼠标切换投影仪上的幻灯片。会议内容很多是关于车辆的，因为 PSD 的大部分工作只是安全地把人从A点送到B点：从巴格达去摩苏尔，从摩苏尔去巴士拉。顺便说一句，在伊拉克的“安全”意味着始终尽可能快地驾驶，以避免被枪击或炸死。所有的安保公司都这样做。为了让安保人员保持自由以扫描道路并在必要时开火，卡斯特-巴特尔使用了伊拉克司机。“巴格达鲍勃”（Baghdad Bob），又名“骗子”（Hustler），认为这有问题，因为看来他们雇佣的伊拉克人，非常可以理解地，一直在拒绝执行他们收到的一些驾驶指示。
These guys own their vehicles. They're not going to ram anybody. They're not going to run anybody over. And the guy told me, quote, unquote yesterday, I go, go! Woo woo woo! "My vehicle." OK, that told me volumes. He ain't going to hit a bump, he ain't going to go, he ain't going to ram somebody.
这些家伙拥有自己的车辆。他们不会撞任何人。他们不会压过任何人。昨天那个家伙对我说，原话引用，我喊道：去！喔喔喔！“我的车。”好吧，这就说明了一切。他不会撞过颠簸，他不会去，他不会撞上某人。
The PSD guys, meanwhile, depend on aggressive driving to protect themselves. If they're surrounded by a hostile crowd, for instance, or if other cars try to box them in for an ambush. But, as Baghdad Bob points out, driving aggressively at the wrong time could also get everyone shot.
与此同时，PSD 队员依赖激进的驾驶来保护自己。例如，如果他们被敌对人群包围，或者如果有其他汽车试图将他们围住进行伏击。但正如巴格达鲍勃指出的，在错误的时间激进驾驶也可能导致所有人被射杀。
We should have the training with the Iraqi drivers. Us sitting in the seat next to an Iraqi driver, this is what you do when you hit a roundabout, this is what you do when you hit a military convoy. Because this is three days in a row I almost got shot by GI Joe. Man, that ain't a good feeling.
我们应该和伊拉克司机进行训练。我们坐在伊拉克司机旁边的座位上，这是你在经过环形交叉路口时应该做的，这是你在遇到军事车队时应该做的。因为这是我连续三天差点被“美国大兵”（GI Joe）射杀。伙计，那感觉可不好。
It becomes clear that the US military is just as much of a danger for the PSD guys as the Iraqi insurgents. Finally, Hank interrupts the discussion with a decision.
很明显，对于 PSD 队员来说，美军和伊拉克叛乱分子一样危险。最后，汉克打断了讨论，做出了决定。
We tell them to ram somebody, we tell them to move over, we buy, we pay for the repairs.
我们告诉他们撞某人，我们告诉他们超过去，我们买，我们支付维修费用。
Problem is, we haven't had a good track record.
问题是，我们的记录一直不太好。
Hank is trying to change some things about the operation. He's here to establish rules and procedures. One result of America's sudden and unprecedented reliance on private security in this war, is that Custer Battles, like many security companies in Iraq, hired a lot of new people very quickly. And Hank is trying to transform them from a bunch of ex-military guys assembled ad hoc to a smooth, standardized workforce, where everyone gets first aid training and regular target practice, good weapons and ammunition, a cell phone, and a uniform, khaki pants, and a navy polo that says Custer Battles on it.
汉克正试图改变行动的一些方面。他在这里是为了建立规则和程序。美国在这次战争中突然且空前地依赖私人安保，其结果之一就是卡斯特-巴特尔像伊拉克的许多安保公司一样，很快雇佣了大量新人。而汉克正试图将他们从一群临时凑在一起的退伍军人变成一支顺畅、标准化的劳动力队伍，让每个人都接受急救训练和常规靶场练习，配备良好的武器和弹药、一部手机，以及一套制服：卡其裤和一件印有卡斯特-巴特尔标志的海军蓝 Polo 衫。
Hank believes in America's mission here in Iraq. He believes private security work is the linchpin in that mission's success. It goes like this. Security guys protect the businessmen trying to start companies in Iraq, and the contractors rebuilding the infrastructure.
汉克相信美国在伊拉克的使命。他相信私人安保工作是该使命成功的关键。它是这样运作的：安保人员保护试图在伊拉克创办公司的商人和重建基础设施的承包商。
If the contractors get the work done, the economy takes off. The average Iraqi looks around and says, we're better off. Kids are going to school. They're making some money. They're buying a used, beat-up Ford Taurus, but they're getting one in their family. They're going to start turning on these, I think, mostly foreign elements. Maybe I ought to contact the authorities. And we're going to find them and root them out, and we're going to make this country great.
如果承包商完成了工作，经济就会起飞。普通伊拉克人环顾四周，会说：“我们过得更好了。孩子们在上学。他们赚了一些钱。他们买了一辆破旧的福特金牛座，但他们家里好歹有一辆了。”他们开始转向这些——我认为——主要是外国的元素。也许我应该联系当局。我们将找到并铲除他们，我们将使这个国家变得伟大。
Hank is not just out to fix Custer Battles. No opportunity for instruction or improvement is missed.
汉克不仅是为了修理卡斯特-巴特尔。任何教学或改进的机会他都不会错过。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
（说外语）
I was paying for my lunch one day, and Hank was talking to the hotel's wait staff. And all of a sudden, Hank and one of the Iraqi staff were gripping hands across the counter and trying to pull each other over. Hank finally grabbed the guy's other hand, so he had both of them, and dragged him halfway across.
有一天我正在付午餐钱，汉克正和酒店的侍者谈话。突然间，汉克和其中一个伊拉克员工在柜台对面握住手，试图把对方拉过来。汉克最后抓住了那家伙的另一只手，所以他两只手都抓住了，把人拖了一半过来。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I stood there watching in amazement.
我站在那里惊奇地看着。
Oh my God. Do you do that with him every day or something?
天哪。你每天都和他玩那个游戏还是怎么的？
We have a game of some kind.
我们玩某种游戏。
Reach across the counter and just try to pull each other over?
隔着柜台握手，然后试着把对方拉过来？
That was a new one. That was a new game.
那是新玩法。那是新游戏。
It was a little disturbing to watch.
看着有点让人不安。
Usually we arm wrestle, or you know, you had a balance game, where you yank the other guy off balance.
通常我们掰手腕，或者你知道，还有一种平衡游戏，就是你把对方拽得失去平衡。
This game of Hank's is not just a game, it's one of his projects. Iraqi men need to work on their upper body strength, he told me more than once. It's very American to say, as George Bush has said, we're not here to change you, we don't want you to become Americans. But we can't help ourselves. Look at Hank. He wants to help, and he knows what will help you. His generosity is interventionist in nature. In the elevator, he explains, it's OK for men to touch each other if they're trying to haul one another over a counter. What's not OK is what he sees Arab men doing every day on the streets of Baghdad.
汉克这个游戏不仅仅是个游戏，这是他的项目之一。他不止一次告诉我，伊拉克男人需要锻炼上半身力量。说“我们不是来改变你们的，我们不想让你们变成美国人”，这非常美国，就像乔治·布什所说的那样。但我们无法控制自己。看看汉克。他想帮忙，而且他知道什么能帮到你。他的慷慨本质上是干涉主义的。在电梯里，他解释说，男人互相接触是可以的，只要他们是在试图把对方拽过柜台。他认为不可接受的是他每天在巴格达街头看到的阿拉伯男人做的事情。
I'm trying to train the Arabs to be less effeminate and quit holding hands, and get to the culture where they--
我正试图训练阿拉伯人变得不那么女性化，停止牵手，达到那种……文化中……
Jesus Christ, let them be! I love that they hold hands.
上帝啊，随他们去吧！我喜欢他们牵手。
OK.
好吧。
The guys walk around arm in arm.
这些家伙手挽手走来走去。
Yeah, it's not right.
是啊，这不对。
Don't train that out of them.
别把这点训练掉。
Don't you think that that's not right?
你不觉得那不对吗？
No, I don't think that that's not right.
不，我不觉得那不对。
OK. [CLEARS THROAT] Well, let's go down to 314.
好吧。（清嗓子）好吧，让我们去314房间。
[GUITAR PLAYING AND SINGING]
（吉他弹唱）
Every Saturday night, Custer Battles PSD guys gather at what they call the viking table in the dining room of the Sinbad Hotel for a big dinner. Tonight, a new guy nicknamed Elvis, because he sings and his last name is Presley, brought his guitar. The table is only half-seated, maybe 15 people out of Custer Battles' 60 PSD guys. I end up sitting near Scott, AKA Grumpy, a heavy Vietnam vet who smokes tiny cigars called Swisher Sweets. Scott's been in Iraq for five months.
每个周六晚上，卡斯特-巴特尔的 PSD 队员都会聚集在辛巴德酒店餐厅里他们所谓的“维京人桌”吃顿大餐。今晚，一个昵称为“猫王”的新人，因为他唱歌且姓普雷斯利，带来了他的吉他。桌子只坐了一半，卡斯特-巴特尔的60名 PSD 队员中大约有15人。我最终坐在了“脾气暴躁”斯科特（Scott AKA Grumpy）旁边，一个臃肿的越战老兵，抽着一种叫“斯威舍甜品”（Swisher Sweets）的小雪茄。斯科特在伊拉克待了五个月了。
I'll probably stay a year. I was going to stay another year, but I don't think my wife's going to buy that. I've been either in the military or law enforcement or security since I was 18 years old. I'm 57 now. So everybody thinks I need to grow up and come on home.
我可能会待一年。我本来打算再待一年，但我觉得我妻子不会同意。从18岁起，我不是在军队就是在执法部门或安保行业。现在我57岁了。所以大家都认为我该长大回家了。
What do you think?
你是怎么想的？
I'm not sure I'm ready to hang up my guns yet. As long as you feel like you can do the job and make a contribution, then you should be here.
我不确定我是不是准备好放下枪了。只要你觉得你能胜任工作并做出贡献，那你就不应该离开。
It's not all about the money, he says. And the guy across from him nods. Most of the PSD guys I talked to said some version of this, the money's good, but I'm also here to help. A few said, I'm here for the adventure. Only two fully embraced the word mercenary. A man named Rob who told me about a mercenary bar in the jungles of Cambodia called Sharky's. They get good bands, he said. And a British guy named Richard who said, I'm here for the money, and so is everyone else.
他说，这不全是为了钱。对面的家伙点点头。我交谈过的大多数 PSD 队员都说过类似的话：钱是很好，但我也在这里提供帮助。几个人说：“我是为了冒险来的。”只有两个人完全拥护“雇佣兵”这个词。一个叫罗布（Rob）的男人告诉我在柬埔寨丛林里有一个叫“鲨鱼”（Sharky's）的雇佣兵酒吧。他们有很好的乐队，他说。还有一个叫理查德（Richard）的英国人说：“我是为了钱来的，其他人也一样。”
I asked the PSD guys if they think we did the right thing by invading Iraq. The responses-- and this ended up being true with everyone I talked to, not just PSD guys-- the responses broke down like this. Around 20% were completely gung-ho: yes, we should have invaded exactly when we did, no questions. Maybe 10% expressed some doubts. And the rest felt like David, an earnest man in his mid-30s with gold-rimmed glasses.
我问 PSD 队员，他们是否认为我们入侵伊拉克是正确的。回答——这最终对我交谈过的每一个人来说都是真实的，不仅仅是 PSD 队员——回答是这样的：大约20%的人完全是“狂热分子”：没错，我们本就该在那时入侵，毫无疑问。大约10%的人表达了一些疑虑。而其余的人感觉像戴维（David），一个30多岁、戴着金丝边眼镜的诚恳男人。
You know what? I don't care. It's over. That part of it's over, it's done with. We're here now. The best thing that we can do is to help these people. And why we're here is over and done.
你知道吗？我不在乎。都过去了。那部分已经过去了，结束了。我们现在在这儿。我们能做的最好的事就是帮助这些人。至于我们为什么在这儿，那已经结束了。
I talked to Tara, a tiny blonde from Grand Rapids, Michigan, who screens passengers out at the Baghdad Airport. An honorary viking princess, Hank calls her. Before coming to Iraq, she'd never been away from home for more than two weeks. She had breakfast with her mom every Tuesday. And while Hank is trying to eliminate physical affection between Iraqi men, Tara has stumbled into her own cheerful project to spread American values.
我采访了来自密歇根州大急流城的金发小个子塔拉（Tara），她在巴格达机场负责筛查乘客。汉克称她为“荣誉维京公主”。在来伊拉克之前，她离开家从未超过两周。她每个周二都和妈妈一起吃早餐。汉克正试图消除伊拉克男人之间的肢体接触，而塔拉则偶然开始了她自己那快乐的传播美国价值观的项目。
I talked to one kid today. He was a cleaner. He cleans the floors at the airport. His wife wears a burka. And it's his choice. He wants her to wear one. And he wanted a cigarette from me. And I said, I'll make a deal with you. I'll give you a cigarette if you let your wife go a week without wearing that.
今天我和一个孩子谈过。他是清洁工。他在机场擦地板。他的妻子戴着面纱。这是他的选择。他想让她戴着。他想问我要根烟。我说，我和你做个交易。如果你让你妻子不戴那个一周，我就给你根烟。
And what did he say?
他怎么说？
He thought about it really hard, and he agreed to it.
他认真考虑了一下，然后同意了。
Oh my God. And did you see her without the burka? Did you confirm that he held up his end of the bargain?
天哪。你有看到她没戴面纱的样子吗？你确认他履行了他的承诺吗？
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
And she came in for a week without it?
她一周都没戴吗？
It actually hasn't been a week yet, but he said, I like it without it. I like her without it on.
其实还没到一周，但他说，我喜欢不戴的样子。我喜欢她不戴的样子。
Before I started doing a story about Custer Battles, a few people advised me against it. That company doesn't have a good reputation, a person pretty high up in the Coalition Provisional Authority told me. I ran all this by Hank, who copped to it immediately.
在我开始制作关于卡斯特-巴特尔的故事之前，一些人劝我不要这样做。 coalition 临时管理当局的一位高层告诉我，那家公司名声不好。我把这些都告诉了汉克，他立刻承认了。
We got a bad reputation, probably as gunslingers. In some circles. My guys I'm riding with right now are coming back soon. I want to have Custer Battles back. But that's within, you know, the last month. Before that, there was some concerns.
我们的名声不好，可能被视为枪手。在某些圈子里。我现在随行的伙计们很快就要回来了。我想让卡斯特-巴特尔回来。但这是在——你知道——过去一个月内的事。在此之前，确实有一些担忧。
Gunslingers was only part of what I'd heard. I told Hank a rumor someone had told me, that Custer Battles had engaged in a huge gun fight at their old hotel, the Al Hayat one night. And when the smoke cleared, it turned out they'd been firing at each other the whole time. No enemy, just Custer Battles guys hearing their own continued gunfire, and believing that meant they were still under attack. Hank confirmed that an event like this had taken place, but it was started by an initial RPG attack on the hotel. He told me what he'd heard from the guys themselves. He got to Iraq after it had happened.
“枪手”只是我听说的一部分。我告诉汉克有人告诉我的一个传言，说卡斯特-巴特尔有天晚上在他们旧酒店“阿尔·哈亚特”（Al Hayat）参与了一场巨大的枪战。当硝烟散去时，结果发现他们一直在互相对射。没有敌人，只有卡斯特-巴特尔的人听到了他们自己持续的枪声，并认为这意味着他们仍在遭到攻击。汉克证实了这种事确实发生过，但它是由对酒店最初的火箭筒（RPG）攻击引发的。他告诉我他从队员那里听到的说法。事情发生后他才到伊拉克。
There was over 3,000 thousand rounds that were launched from the hotel, except for an RPG attack. Everybody seen everybody in the streets, and everybody was hanging out their windows, emptying magazines into the shadows. And then the report was that we had four dead guys out there that we'd gotten.
酒店发射了超过3000发子弹，除了RPG攻击。每个人都看到街上到处都是人，每个人都从窗户探出身子，对着阴影清空弹匣。然后报告说我们杀了四个家伙。
And of course, I always ask-- I wasn't here then-- I'd say, did you bring the bodies in? No. Did you get a blood trail? No, they dragged him off. They scrubbed the blood trails up. Damn those people, those bastards. How are we going to win this war? They're so quick to sterilize the scene. Answer was, opening day jitters. Everybody's seeing shadows, everybody else is shooting like crazy.
当然，我总是问——我那时不在那儿——我说：“你们把尸体带进来了吗？”没有。“你们有血迹吗？”没有，他们拖走了。他们把血迹擦洗干净了。诅咒那些人，那些混蛋。我们怎么才能赢得这场战争？他们那么快就清理了现场。答案是：开战首日的紧张感。每个人都在看到阴影，每个人都在疯狂射击。
To be clear, all this shooting, those 3,000 rounds fired from the hotel, went out into a residential neighborhood in Baghdad. It's likely that, as Hank believes, no one was injured or killed, in spite of all this firepower. Nobody came forward with bodies. But, and this is an important but, there was no formal investigation of the incident, not by the Iraqi police, not by the US military. And Custer Battles, though it did its own internal investigation, wasn't required to report it to anyone.
需要明确的是，所有这些射击，从酒店发出的那3000发子弹，都射向了巴格达的一个居民区。正如汉克所信，尽管火力如此猛烈，但可能没人受伤或死亡。没人拿着尸体找上门。但是——这是一个重要的“但是”——没有对该事件进行正式调查，不是伊拉克警察，也不是美军。虽然卡斯特-巴特尔进行了自己的内部调查，但并没有要求向任何人报告。
The Custer Battles people I met seemed to be steady men, not trigger happy. Hank, for instance, has never shot a person in his life, even after years in the army and months in Iraq. But all of them, like the employees of every other security company in Iraq, are operating in a context where the rules aren't clear. This is all so new, having over 60 private security firms, some with their own helicopters, their own heavy arms, operating in the middle of a war zone, not subject to the same rules as the military, but not necessarily subject to any other rules.
我见到的卡斯特-巴特尔人看起来都很稳重，并不是乱开枪的人。例如，汉克这辈子从来没射杀过人，尽管他在军队服役多年，在伊拉克也待了好几个月。但他们所有人，就像伊拉克其他每家安保公司的员工一样，都在规则不明确的环境中运作。这一切太新了，有超过60家私人安保公司，有的拥有自己的直升机、重型武器，在战区中心运营，不受军队同样的规则约束，但也不一定受任何其他规则约束。
Right now, the US government is trying to invent some new guidelines. But they're not in place yet. In Iraq, there are no clear consequences for making a mistake, or for being reckless.
现在，美国政府正试图制定一些新指南。但它们尚未落实。在伊拉克，犯错或鲁莽行事没有任何明确后果。
People are shooting and not being held accountable for shooting people? Ah, I suppose there's a lot of that going on. And I think in this brief period of time, just like in the Wild West, you control your own company. You can assert a little bit of control in your own little world and hold people accountable there. I guess, to answer your question, I'm not that concerned about it.
人们在射击却不用为射杀他人负责？啊，我想这种情况很多。而且我认为在这短暂的时期里，就像在“狂野西部”，你可以控制你自己的公司。你可以为你自己的小世界断言一点点控制力，并让人承担责任。我想，回答你的问题，我并不太担心这一点。
Hank's handle on the walkie talkie system is Krom, K-R-O-M, the god Conan prays to in Conan the Barbarian. Mighty Duck is the operations manager.
汉克在对讲机系统上的代号是“克罗姆”（Krom），K-R-O-M，那是《野蛮人柯南》中柯南祈祷的神。代号“威猛鸭”（Mighty Duck）的是运营经理。
Mighty Duck, Krom. Just got a call from Rock. There's about 2,000 protesters at gates 1, 2, and 3 into the Green Zone. Break.
威猛鸭，我是克罗姆。刚接到摇滚的电话。在绿区的1、2、3号门有大约2000名抗议者。完毕。
Roger.
收到。
They expect the crowd to get violent and to increase in size. Can you get word out via Arachna to our teams that are out?
他们预计人群会变得暴力，规模会增加。你能通过 Arachna 向我们在外面的团队传达一下吗？
Roger.
收到。
This protest on April 2 was the beginning of the violent struggle between the US and followers of Shiite cleric Muqtada Al-Sadr, the beginning of the deadliest month for US forces since the start of the war. It was also two days after four private security guys from a company called Blackwater were killed in Fallujah, and parts of their bodies hung from a bridge, a grinning crowd of Iraqis surrounding their burnt car. If they got Blackwater, a Custer Battles guy told me, it's scary, because Blackwater's the best.
这次4月2日的抗议活动是美国与什叶派教士穆克塔达·萨德尔（Muqtada Al-Sadr）追随者之间暴力斗争的开始，也是自战争开始以来美军最惨烈月份的开端。这也是黑水（Blackwater）公司四名私人安保人员在费卢杰被杀后的两天，他们的部分尸体被悬挂在桥上，一群满脸堆笑的伊拉克人围着他们烧毁的汽车。一个卡斯特-巴特尔的人告诉我，如果他们连黑水都搞定了，那就太可怕了，因为黑水是最强的。
Is there anything that could happen, that you know now as sort of that's your enough-is-enough mark?
有什么事会发生，让你觉得这就是“忍无可忍”的界限吗？
Me personally?
对我个人来说？
Yeah, you personally.
是的，你个人。
No. You mean as far as things getting so bad I want to get out of here?
没有。你是说情况变得太糟，让我想要离开这里吗？
Yeah.
是的。
That would be cowardice, if things got bad and you wanted to get out. Wouldn't it? So even if I really wanted to get out, I probably wouldn't admit it to myself.
如果情况变糟了，你还想要离开，那将是懦弱的行为。不是吗？所以即使我真的很想离开，我可能也不会向自己承认。
In the weeks after I left, right after Fallujah, the violence escalated, not because of the pictures from Abu Ghraib prison, Hank told me. Those weren't the turning point. Even before the pictures were made public, there were three weeks, Hank said, when it was hard to go anywhere without getting shot at. Americans hunkered down in hotels, including security people.
在我离开后的几周里，就在费卢杰事件后，暴力升级，并不是因为阿布格莱布监狱的照片，汉克告诉我。那并不是转折点。汉克说，甚至在照片公布之前，就有三周时间，如果不遭到枪击，几乎哪儿也去不了。美国人躲在酒店里，包括安保人员。
When there were missions, his men would ask about whether they were really necessary, and the quality of the available intelligence. Four different times, men refused to go on missions, Hank said. And there were casualties. Elvis, who played guitar at the viking dinner, was shot in the leg when the hotel was sprayed with gunfire. Dave Shoe, the guy you heard at the beginning of the show, who got into that argument with the major at the airport, was ambushed in his car and shot in the head. He's OK.
当有任务时，他的手下会询问这些任务是否真的有必要，以及现有情报的质量。汉克说，有四次，手下拒绝执行任务。而且出现了伤亡。在维京晚宴上弹吉他的“猫王”在酒店遭到枪林弹雨扫射时，腿部中弹。节目开始时你听到的那个在机场与少校争论的戴夫·舒，在车里遭到伏击，头部中弹。他没事。
And one of their British guys was killed execution-style, pulled from his car in a crowd and shot in the back of the head. People were badly shaken, Hank said. But no one's quit so far.
他们其中一个英国人以行刑方式被杀，在人群中被从车里拉出来，后脑勺中弹。汉克说，人们受到了严重惊吓。但到目前为止，没人辞职。
Nancy Updike. In the year since we first broadcast this program, Hank says that 11 Custer Battles security guys have been killed. And Custer Battles itself has been banned from getting government contracts in Iraq, after federal investigators found that it billed for all kinds of work that it never did, defrauding the war effort of at least $50 million, allegedly. The company denies the charges. The case is in court. Other private contractors face similar charges. Halliburton has $1.8 billion, that's billion, in disputed billings in Iraq. Coming up, when is a shovel not a shovel? That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
南希·厄普代克。在我们首次播出这个节目的这一年中，汉克说已有11名卡斯特-巴特尔安保人员丧生。卡斯特-巴特尔公司本身已被禁止在伊拉克获得政府合同，此前联邦调查人员发现它为各种它从未做过的工作开具账单，涉嫌欺诈了至少5000万美元的战争资金。该公司否认了这些指控。案件正在审理中。其他私人承包商也面临类似指控。哈里伯顿公司（Halliburton）在伊拉克有18亿美元，注意是“十亿”，处于争议账单中。接下来，铁锹在什么时候不再是铁锹？一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, we're devoting our entire program to Nancy Updike's report on civilian contractors in Iraq. She was there in April 2004, and we first broadcast her story a year ago. But the situation with private military contractors working in Iraq hasn't changed that much. It's still one private contractor for every six US military personnel. To give you a sense of how unprecedented that number is, having that many civilians working alongside the US army in the middle of a war zone, back in the first Gulf War, it was one private contractor for every 60 military personnel. By some estimates, a quarter of all the reconstruction money for Iraq will go to these private security firms.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们整个节目都致力于南希·厄普代克的报道，关于伊拉克的民用承包商。她于2004年4月在那里，我们一年前首次播出了她的故事。但私人军事承包商在伊拉克的处境并没有太大改变。仍然是每六名美军人员就有一名私人承包商。为了让你感受一下这个数字是多么空前，在战区中心与美军一起工作的人员中，平民比例如此之高，而在第一次海湾战争中，每60名军事人员才有一名私人承包商。据估计，伊拉克所有重建资金的四分之一将流向这些私人安保公司。
We resume Nancy's story at the Green Zone, which at the time was where the American operation in Iraq was based, A four-square-mile area in Baghdad, surrounded by 15-foot walls and barbed wire, with US soldiers guarding the only entrances. Lots of private contractors live or work there, alongside thousands of soldiers and government workers. Here's Nancy.
我们回到南希在绿区的故事，当时那里是美国在伊拉克行动的基地，一个巴格达4平方英里的区域，被15英尺高的墙和铁丝网包围，美军守卫着唯一的入口。许多私人承包商在那里生活或工作，与数千名士兵和政府工作人员在一起。下面由南希带来报道。
The Green Zone is a sprawl, like Los Angeles, a big, hot, paved sprawl full of humvees and SUVs, and men and women jogging along the wide roads in shorts. You never see that anywhere else in Baghdad. There's a disco at the Al Rashid hotel on Saturday nights in the Green Zone, karaoke on Friday's, taekwondo, an internet cafe, and a long outdoor flea market with Iraqi kids selling CDs, or movies and porn on DVD, fanny packs, makeup, satellite dishes, also a variety of Saddam-themed lighters and watches. It seems the final stage of a brutal dictatorship is kitsch.
绿区是一片蔓延的区域，像洛杉矶一样，是一片炎热、铺着路面、到处都是悍马和SUV的巨大空间，男男女女穿着短裤在宽阔的道路上慢跑。你在巴格达其他任何地方都看不到这种景象。绿区的阿尔-拉希德酒店（Al Rashid hotel）周六晚上有迪斯科，周五有卡拉OK、跆拳道、互联网咖啡馆，还有一个长长的户外跳蚤市场，伊拉克孩子出售CD，DVD电影和色情制品，腰包，化妆品，卫星天线，还有各种萨达姆主题的打火机和手表。似乎残暴独裁统治的最后阶段就是庸俗艺术。
A few restaurants have also sprung up in the Green Zone, including a Chinese place that is so obscurely located, it's like the gay bars of the 50s. You have to go with someone who already knows where it is. Otherwise, why would you ever walk through the chipped opening in the stone wall next to the hospital, and go down the long, rubble filled alley? And if you did, how would you know to make a left into the small, crab-grassy courtyard with plastic chairs and tables with boxes of tissue on them?
绿区也出现了一些餐馆，包括一家中餐馆，地理位置极其隐蔽，就像50年代的同性恋酒吧。你必须和已经知道它在哪里的人一起去。否则，你为什么要穿过医院旁边石墙上的那个碎裂的开口，走过充满瓦砾的长长巷子？如果你进去了，你怎么会知道向左转进入那个带有塑料桌椅和餐巾纸盒的杂草丛生的小院子呢？
In any other part of the world, this place would not survive. In addition to its difficult-to-find entrance, the restaurant is right next to a helipad. But this place is thriving. It is a monument to the power of word of mouth, and to the desperation created by the fact that daily fare for most Americans in the Green Zone is meals at a cafeteria where food is prepared for thousands of people at a time. Dragon Chinese restaurant is also a testament to the axiom, which I'm coining here, that Kung Pao chicken will always find a way to exist wherever Americans are present.
在世界任何其他地方，这个地方都无法生存。除了难以找到的入口外，餐馆就在直升机停机坪旁边。但这地方生意兴隆。它是口碑力量的纪念碑，也是因为在绿区大多数美国人的日常饮食是在食堂里，那里是一次性为数千人准备食物的事实所造成的绝望的纪念碑。龙腾中餐馆（Dragon Chinese restaurant）也证明了我在 coined（创造）的一个公理：只要有美国人在场，宫保鸡丁总会找到存在的方式。
I want the Kung Pao chicken.
我要宫保鸡丁。
Number eight?
8号？
Yeah, number eight.
是的，8号。
I've come to the restaurant with a group of guys who work for Fluor Corporation, which is under contract to the Army Corps of Engineers to help rebuild the electricity system in Iraq. Fluor asked me to use only the first names of their employees for their safety and that of their families. Everyone here has had a long day, mostly sitting at the airport in Kuwait waiting for a military transport plane to Baghdad. We begin drinking immediately.
我和一组为氟公司（Fluor Corporation）工作的人一起来到这家餐馆，他们受雇于陆军工程兵团，帮助重建伊拉克的电力系统。氟公司要求我只使用他们员工的名字，为了他们的安全和他们家人的安全。这里的每个人都度过了漫长的一天，大部分时间都在科威特的机场等待军用运输机飞往巴格达。我们立即开始喝酒。
Perhaps in the spirit of imagining ways to unwind, the Fluor guys start talking about whether it's true what they've heard about there being a brothel in the Green Zone. And if that's true, is it possible that a person could, as it were, order in?
也许本着想象放松方式的精神，氟公司的家伙们开始讨论他们听说的关于绿区有一家妓院的传言是否属实。如果是真的，一个人是否可能——可以说——叫外卖？
You were told that for $50--
有人告诉你花50美元——
Might have been $20, I don't know. I'd have paid-- I don't do it, but, somebody said it was either $20 or $50, you could have them brought to you, to your trailer. [LAUGHTER]
可能是20美元，我不知道。我会付钱的——我没做过，但，有人说要么是20要么是50，你可以让他们送到你这儿，送到你的拖车里。（笑声）
Do some investigative reporting.
去做点调查性报道吧。
And you let us know! And if you do find one, let me know what the address is.
然后让我们知道！如果你真的找到了一个，告诉我地址是什么。
By the time I was listening to this conversation at this restaurant, I had been in Baghdad two weeks. And I'd stopped counting the number of times a day when I thought, wow, it really is all men here.
当我在这家餐馆听着这段对话时，我在巴格达已经待了两周了。我已经数不清一天里有多少次我想：“哇，这儿真全都是男人。”
Mike from Texas starts out on a small tear. He's 30 years old with dark blue eyes, and a blonde moustache growing down the sides of his mouth. He instigates the brothel conversation, then orders a bottle of Captain Morgan rum, for himself. But the evening surprisingly gets less rowdy as it goes on. It turns out Mike is a geek, though a kind I've never encountered before, a power plant geek. He's really, really into what he does: the job, the tools.
来自德州的迈克（Mike）开始了一阵小小的吐槽。他30岁，有着深蓝色的眼睛，嘴两侧长着金色的胡子。他挑起了那个妓院的话题，然后为自己点了一瓶摩根船长朗姆酒。但随着夜晚的深入，情况出人意料地不再那么吵闹。事实证明迈克是个极客，尽管是一种我从未遇到过的极客：发电厂极客。他真的，真的很投入他所做的事情：工作，工具。
Absolutely, I want to see the kind of equipment they've got. Not only plant equipment and power producing equipment, I want to see what kind of cranes and logistical equipment we've got on site, and that sort of thing.
绝对，我想看看他们有什么样的设备。不仅是工厂设备和发电设备，我想看看我们现场有什么样的起重机和后勤设备，诸如此类的东西。
He wants to see the cranes. The conversation gets more and more inside. Shim stock. Couplings. Pipe guys versus mechanical guys.
他想看看起重机。对话变得越来越内行。垫片。联轴器。管道工与机械工之争。
And then you got civil guys that want you to set the pipe and set the machinery to the grade of the concrete. It's like, no, it don't work like that.
然后你有土木工程师想让你根据混凝土的等级设置管道和机器。就好像，不，不是那样工作的。
There are guys who come to Iraq who know guns, and do guns. And then there are guys who come to Iraq who are technicians, or specialists, in some area. Geeks. Sewage geeks. Water geeks. Refinery geeks. Electricity geeks.
有来到伊拉克的懂枪且做安保的家伙。也有来到伊拉克的技术员，或特定领域的专家。极客。污水极客。水资源极客。炼油厂极客。电力极客。
I drive out to a power plant near Baghdad with Lee, who's supervising Fluor's work there. He is a solid man in big, square glasses with mousy hair you wouldn't guess was 57. Lee has done just about every power plant job there is. He's not flashy, but men follow him. A few told me they only came to Iraq because Lee asked them. After about an hour and a half, we turn onto a road that's suddenly quite rural, mostly small houses, farmland, lots of kids outside.
我开车去巴格达附近的一座发电厂，李（Lee）在监督氟公司在那里的工作。他是一个坚实的人，戴着大大的方形眼镜，灰褐色头发，你不会猜到他57岁了。李几乎做过所有发电厂的工作。他不张扬，但人们追随他。几个人告诉我，他们来伊拉克只是因为李邀请了他们。大约一个半小时后，我们转上一条突然变得相当乡村的道路，主要是小房子、农田，外面有很多孩子。
These kids are standing and waving and giving you the thumbs up. Does this happen every time you come by?
这些孩子站着招手，竖起大拇指。你每次经过都会这样吗？
Oh, yeah. Yeah. When you don't see the children, there's a problem. If you don't see the kids that you normally see, you need to stop and find another way to it, because there's probably something out there that you don't want to get into, whether it's an IED--
哦，是的。是的。当你没看到孩子的时候，就有问题了。如果你没看到你平时看到的孩子，你就需要停下来，换条路走，因为前面可能有你不想卷入的东西，无论是简易爆炸装置（IED）——
IED, improvised explosive device.
IED，即简易爆炸装置。
--an ambush, one of 100 different things it could be.
——伏击，可能是100种不同情况中的一种。
Lee is unflappable. I know this, because 40 minutes before we saw these kids waving, we were in a traffic jam leaving Baghdad and got ambushed and shot at. It happened fast. My tape machine was off because Lee had been telling me about Fluor's security procedures and I'd agreed not to record that in order to keep them secret. As he was talking, we both saw a black BMW weaving aggressively in between the cars. We noted, without alarm, that this was, according to the private security guys in Iraq, the typical bad guy car. And it was driving in the typical bad guy way that private security guys were always warning about.
李是不可动摇的。我知道这一点，因为在我们看到这些孩子招手的40分钟前，我们在离开巴格达的交通堵塞中遭到了伏击和枪击。发生得很快。我的录音机没开，因为李一直在告诉我氟公司的安保程序，我同意不记录那些，以保持机密。当他说话时，我们都看到一辆黑色宝马在车流中激进地穿梭。我们没有惊慌地注意到，根据伊拉克的私人安保人员的说法，这是一辆典型的坏人车。而且它正以私人安保人员总是警告的那种典型坏人方式驾驶。
And then, suddenly, it cut right in front of the first car in our convoy, the one just ahead of us, and stopped short. And we heard the fake sounding pop pop of real gunfire, and saw Fluor's security guys in the car ahead of us get out and start shooting.
然后，突然，它直接切入我们车队的第一辆车前面，也就是我们前面那辆，然后猛地停住。我们听到了像假的一样的“砰砰”真实枪声，看到前面车里的氟公司安保人员下车开始射击。
OK, OK. You're fine.
好的，好的。你没事。
You can hear Lee and his driver reassuring me, OK, OK, you're all right, you're fine. The driver even tapped the glass to remind me we were in an armored car. I'd forgotten, but I don't think I would have been less frightened if I'd remembered. Cars were stopped all around us, ordinary Iraqis caught in a shoot-out. We were trapped too, until the BMW sped off and disappeared into traffic. Then we drove off. We never found out where the car went, who was in it.
你可以听到李和他的司机安慰我：“好的，好的，你没事，你没事的。”司机甚至敲了敲玻璃提醒我我们坐在装甲车里。我忘了，但我认为如果我记得的话，我不会那么害怕。车子在我们周围停了下来，普通的伊拉克人被困在交火中。我们也陷入了困境，直到宝马加速离开，消失在车流中。然后我们开车离开了。我们永远不知道那辆车去了哪里，里面是谁。
I saw them come in front of us and stop.
我看到他们来到我们前面然后停下。
You're all right. You're fine. [LAUGHTER] It ain't going to bother me.
你没事。你没事的。（笑声）这不会困扰我。
[LAUGHING] Why, why are you laughing? We just got shot at.
（笑声）为什么，你为什么笑？我们刚才被枪击了。
I've been here for nine months. This is probably the hundredth time.
我在这儿待了九个月了。这大概是第一百次了。
You've been shot at?
你被枪击过？
I've had RPGs across the roof. I've had 62-millimeter mortar rounds hit in front. I've had the back end blown out of two vehicles. Some IEDs.
我的车顶上中过 RPG。我的前面落过62毫米迫击炮弹。我有两辆车的后部被炸毁。一些 IED。
Are you a drinking man?
你是个爱喝酒的人吗？
Nope, nope. Doesn't bother me.
不，不。那不会困扰我。
Just explain that.
解释一下。
I've worked in too many countries that's been in violent conflicts. East Timor. Vietnam. Cambodia. Chad. Peru, during the Shining Path. I mean, this is just a common occurrence.
我在太多发生暴力冲突的国家工作过。东帝汶。越南。柬埔寨。乍得。秘鲁，在“光辉道路”期间。我的意思是，这只是常见现象。
Is this better or worse?
这次是更好了还是更糟？
This is more intense here. We've not had any incidents with our people. We've had none of our Western ex-pats have been hurt.
这里更激烈。我们的人还没出过事。我们的西方外籍人士一个都没受伤。
Have any Iraqi workers been hurt?
有伊拉克工人受伤吗？
Well, that's another story. That is, yes, that is a fact.
嗯，那是另一个故事了。那是，是的，那是事实。
Lee asked me to turn the tape machine off again, though he said I could write down what he was saying. Six of Fluor's Iraqi security guards were killed when they blocked a suicide bomber's car. His own secretary, an Iraqi woman, was gunned down and killed in front of her house. He doesn't know why. He assumes it's because she was working for an American, him.
李再次要求我关掉录音机，尽管他说我可以记下他在说什么。当氟公司的伊拉克安保人员阻挡自杀式炸弹汽车时，有六人被炸死。他自己的秘书，一名伊拉克女性，在她家门前遭到枪杀。他不知道原因。他假设是因为她在为美国人工作，为他工作。
A power plant is magnificent. If you ever get a chance to walk around inside one, do it. It's a world on another scale. 60-foot fuel tanks and hundreds of yards of huge metal tubing. A transformer that looks like a multi-armed robot on its way out to crush houses. Cranes, just like Mike from the Chinese restaurant wanted to see.
发电厂是壮丽的。如果你有机会走进去看看，一定要去。它是另一个规模的世界。60英尺高的油箱和数百码长的巨大金属管道。一个看起来像多臂机器人的变压器在要去压碎房子。起重机，就像中国餐馆的迈克想看的那样。
This is a 450-ton crane. Biggest crane in Iraq.
这是一台450吨的起重机。伊拉克最大的起重机。
Right here.
就在这儿。
You know that thing in your house that kind of works but is really falling apart, and needs to be just taken out and replaced, or at least given a total overhaul, but, unless it breaks down completely, you're just going to keep it the way it is? That is Iraq's entire electricity system. Lee spent over an hour spelling out its problems for me.
你知道你家里那个勉强能用，但实际上快散架了，需要被拆掉换新，或者至少进行大修，但除非它完全坏掉，否则你只会保持原样的那个东西吗？那就是伊拉克的整个电力系统。李花了一个多小时为我详述它的问题。
Even before the war, electricity would go on and off. Very little of the power grid was damaged during the war, according to the Army Corps of Engineers. The bigger problem is that most power plants in Iraq are at least 20 years old, and were starved by Saddam Hussein of money and parts for years. During sanctions, the plants fell apart even more. Iraqis who were glad to see America get rid of Saddam Hussein, now don't understand why, more than a year after the US invaded, promising to make their lives better, they're still dealing with blackouts every day.
即使在战争之前，电力也会时断时续。据陆军工程兵团称，电网在战争期间几乎没受到什么损坏。更大的问题是，伊拉克的大多数发电厂至少有20年历史了，并且多年来一直被萨达姆·侯赛因剥夺了金钱和零部件。在制裁期间，这些工厂更加破烂不堪。伊拉克人很高兴看到美国除掉了萨达姆·侯赛因，现在却不明白为什么美国入侵一年多后，承诺让他们的生活变得更好，他们仍然每天都要应对停电。
Electricity, after security, is the number-one frustration for a lot of Iraqis. Lee knows this. Fluor employees are working seven days a week, 12 to 15 hours a day, trying to fix six plants at once, at each one, cramming work that should take a year or more into seven months. Everything is a problem. Every one of the 28 power plants in Iraq, like a snowflake, is a unique apparatus, jerry-rigged and retrofitted and carefully taped together by Iraqi workers for years. This means repair at every plant must also be unique.
电力，在安保之后，是许多伊拉克人的第一大痛点。李知道这一点。氟公司的员工每周工作七天，每天12到15小时，试图同时修理六个工厂，在每一个工厂，将本应花费一年或更长时间的工作挤在七个月内完成。一切都是问题。伊拉克的28个发电厂中的每一个，就像雪花一样，都是一种独特的装置，被伊拉克工人多年来临时拼凑、改装并小心翼翼地用胶带粘在一起。这意味着每个工厂的维修也必须是独特的。
All parts and equipment need to be imported. There's no manufacturing inside Iraq. There's also a worldwide shortage right now of exactly the big machines that are the guts of power plants. Plus, there's the looting, which everyone talks about, but it's hard to picture just how devastating it must have been, until you're standing in a 320-acre power plant, in which every gauge, valve, wire, small motor, and scrap of metal that wasn't nailed down or too heavy to move, was carted off.
所有部件和设备都需要进口。伊拉克内部没有制造业。目前，正是那些作为发电厂核心的大型机器在全世界范围内短缺。此外，还有掠夺，每个人都在谈论，但在你站在一个320英亩的发电厂里，看到每一个刻度盘、阀门、电线、小马达和不是被钉死或太重无法移动的废金属都被运走之前，很难想象它一定有多么具有毁灭性。
Rick Moore, the site manager, a tall, thin man from Oklahoma who needs to use more sunblock, says anything left behind was junky at a very special and rarely seen level of junkiness.
里克·摩尔（Rick Moore），现场经理，一个来自俄克拉荷马州、需要涂更多防晒霜的高个子瘦男人说，留下的任何东西都是一种非常特殊且罕见的垃圾级别。
You know, even something as simple as a shovel, when we first got here, a shovel would be wore out, if you could really think that you could do that. But the metal would actually have been wore almost all the way down because they'd used it so much.
你知道，即使是像铁锹这样简单的东西，当我们刚到这儿时，铁锹都已经磨损了，如果你真的能想象你能做到那样的话。但金属实际上几乎被磨到底部了，因为他们用得太频繁了。
Karen Hahn is different from most people you've heard so far. She doesn't work with big equipment. She's never been in the military. She's from north of the Mason Dixon line. She's a she. And she loves being in Iraq. She loves it so much that she sounds happy, even if she's talking about screening bags at the Baghdad airport, which is the first job she had when she got here last summer. Here's why Iraq has made her so happy.
卡伦·哈恩（Karen Hahn）和你到目前为止听到的大多数人都不一样。她不和大型设备一起工作。她从未在军队服役。她来自梅森-迪克森线（Mason-Dixon line）以北。她是个女的。而且她喜欢在伊拉克。她如此喜欢这里，以至于她听起来很开心，即使是在谈论在巴格达机场筛查行李，这是她去年刚来这里时的第一份工作。这就是为什么伊拉克让她如此开心的原因。
A year ago, she was a divorced, underemployed single mother who was deeply in debt and felt cursed. She'd get a job, and a few months later, like clockwork, the company or branch would go under. This happened six times. She got to the point where she would say in job interviews, if you hire me, your company is doomed. She was broke. She was depressed.
一年前，她是一个离婚、就业不足的单身母亲，负债累累，觉得自己被诅咒了。她找到一份工作，几个月后，像发条一样，公司或分部就会倒闭。这种情况发生了六次。她到了面试时会说：“如果你雇我，你们公司就完蛋了”的地步。她破产了。她很抑郁。
Finally, she got a job as a screener at the Greater Rochester International Airport. She'd only been doing it a few months when they asked for volunteers to go to Baghdad. Her hand shot up, to her own surprise. She flew out 10 days later, leaving her 11-year-old daughter with her ex-husband. Working for Custer Battles has changed her life. She's been promoted three times in the last year, and is now running their human resources department in Iraq, living a life she couldn't have imagined a year ago, and making bank.
终于，她在罗切斯特大国际机场得到了一份安检员的工作。她才做了几个月，他们就招募志愿者去巴格达。出乎意料的是，她举手了。10天后她就飞走了，把她11岁的女儿留给了前夫。为卡斯特-巴特尔工作改变了她的人生。她在过去一年里被提升了三次，现在负责他们在伊拉克的人力资源部门，过着她一年前无法想象的生活，而且赚到了钱。
It's incredible to me. I can't imagine my life getting any better than it is now with work and life experiences.
这对我来说太不可思议了。我无法想象我的生活比现在的工作和生活经历更好。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah. Well, that's why I wake up happy every day. Some people wake up and they go, oh, it's another beautiful day in Baghdad. But I mean it. That's another thing. My boss likes to tease me about the Baghdad weight loss plan, because I lost about 25 pounds since I've been here.
是的。嗯，这就是为什么我每天醒来都很开心。有些人醒来会说，“哦，又是巴格达美丽的一天。”但我是认真的。那是另一回事。我的老板喜欢拿“巴格达减肥计划”取笑我，因为我来这里之后瘦了大约25磅。
Get out.
别开玩笑了。
No.
没开玩笑。
That's amazing. Why do you think that is?
那太惊人了。你认为是什么原因？
Well, the lack of depression-eating. That always helps. Doesn't that sound funny? [LAUGHTER]
嗯，不再靠“抑郁性进食”了。这总是有帮助的。听起来是不是很滑稽？（笑声）
You came to Baghdad to relax and lose weight.
你来巴格达是为了放松和减肥。
Yes. My Baghdad spa.
是的。我的“巴格达水疗中心”。
Karen knows it's a luxury to feel this way in Baghdad. She's living at the airport as well as working there, and it's a big, protected American enclave, like the Green Zone, surrounded by walls and guarded by soldiers, mostly insulated from the hazards of the rest of Baghdad. She tells a story about an Iraqi woman who flew into the airport. Her husband, child, and mother-in-law had just been killed. From a car bomb, Karen thinks.
卡伦知道在巴格达有这种感觉是一种奢侈。她也住在机场，那里是一个巨大的、受保护的美国飞地，就像绿区一样，四周有墙，有士兵守卫，大部分时间与巴格达其他地方的危险隔绝。她讲了一个飞进机场的伊拉克女人的故事。她的丈夫、孩子和婆婆刚被杀害。卡伦认为是汽车炸弹。
She flies in. And we're just trying to get this woman, this horribly, horribly distraught woman. I don't know how she did it. A cry I've never heard before in my life. We just, you know, got their vehicles airside, and helped out with immigration quite a bit, and we sent somebody to go get their bags, and made it so that she hardly didn't have to move and had some privacy. Oh, I was crying. I was crying so much. But I still have to do my job. But I'm just doing it crying.
她飞了进来。我们只是试图让这个女人，这个极其、极其心烦意乱的女人……我不知道她是怎么做到的。那是这辈子我从未听过的哭声。我们只是，你知道，把他们的车辆送到了空侧，在移民问题上帮了很多忙，我们派人去拿他们的行李，让她几乎不需要动，并且有了一些隐私。哦，我哭了。我哭得太厉害了。但我仍然必须做我的工作。我只是边做边哭。
And they came back a week later to thank me, stopped to thank me. And I wasn't even working that day. And I got called down from my office to go and talk to them so that they could all give me hugs and kisses and thank me. And they said, I couldn't believe it! They said, I'm looking up and I'm crying, and all of a sudden, I see this tall woman wearing a gun, crying like a baby. And I said, I'm so sorry, I'm just so sorry. And I hugged and kissed all of them. And I'm glad I'm here. I'm glad that was me.
一周后他们回来感谢我，特地来感谢我。那天我甚至没上班。我被叫下办公室去和他们谈话，这样他们都能给我拥抱和吻，感谢我。他们说：“我简直不敢相信！”他们说：“我抬头看着，我正在哭，突然间，我看到这个戴着枪的高个子女人，哭得像个婴儿。”我说：“我太抱歉了，我真的太抱歉了。”我拥抱并亲吻了他们所有人。我很高兴我在这儿。我很高兴那是我。
The major crimes unit in Baghdad is in a small, grungy yellow building, like an old public school, with corridors dotted with small offices, each one with a desk, and a chair, and a guy, no computers. Jerry Burke is here for an inspection. He's a 57-year-old former Boston beat cop and detective, hired by the Department of Justice to be a mentor and adviser for Iraqi police, to help them build a modern police force. He's exactly the guy you'd want to be in Iraq, doing his job and meeting Iraqis. He respects and understands police work and human rights laws. He's patient, knowledgeable, and, frankly, cuddly.
巴格达的重大犯罪部门在一个破旧的黄色小楼里，就像一所老公立学校，走廊上点缀着小办公室，每个办公室里有一张桌子、一把椅子和一个家伙，没有电脑。杰瑞·伯克（Jerry Burke）来这里进行视察。他是一位57岁的前波士顿巡警和侦探，被司法部雇佣来担任伊拉克警察的导师和顾问，帮助他们建立现代警察部队。他正是你想在伊拉克看到的那种人，做着自己的工作，接触着伊拉克人。他尊重并理解警察工作和人权法。他耐心、知识渊博，而且，坦白说，很可爱。
Unannounced, they don't know I'm coming.
未预先通知，他们不知道我要来。
The kind of cuddly, though, that believes in surprise inspections. The Iraqi police guarding the jail open a locked metal door and show us into an area that opens to a filthy bathroom on one end, and has two rooms off to the right, stuffy, but relatively clean, each with about 50 men sitting on blankets on the floor, staring at us.
不过，那是相信突击视察的那种可爱。看守监狱的伊拉克警察打开了一扇锁着的金属门，带我们进入一个区域，一头通向一个肮脏的浴室，右边有两个房间，闷热，但相对干净，每个房间大约有50个人坐在地板上的毯子上，盯着我们看。
This here is the most serious criminals: murderers, rapists, robbers, carjackers.
这里是最严重的罪犯：谋杀犯、强奸犯、抢劫犯、劫车犯。
What are you looking for?
你在找什么？
Just generally appearance, make sure none of the prisoners have been beaten, or seemingly injured while in custody. They do seem to be intimidated by the staff. They are getting on their knees.
只是整体外观，确保没有囚犯被殴打，或者在拘留期间受伤。他们看起来确实被工作人员震慑住了。他们正跪着。
Yeah, they are sort of getting in cross-legged position. So what do you take from that?
是的，他们正处于那种盘腿的姿势。那你从中得出什么结论？
That the jail staff probably are sometimes forcing compliance.
那里的监狱工作人员可能有时在强迫顺从。
And what do you do about that?
那你打算怎么办？
At this point, we talk to the General, just make sure none of them are being beaten. And I don't see any obvious signs of beatings, no bandages, no black eyes, no bloody scars or anything like that. I mean, this is good compared to before.
目前，我们和将军谈谈，确保没人被殴打。我没看到任何明显的殴打迹象，没绷带，没黑眼圈，没血痕之类的。我的意思是，这比以前好多了。
When he first got to Baghdad, Jerry says, beatings were common in jail and food was not. If your family brought you food, great. If they didn't, too bad. Now Baghdad jails are providing two meals a day, he said, the Red Cross standard. Overcrowding can still be a problem, sometimes over 100 men packed into a room that's full at 50. Jerry checks in with the commander, General Rod, confers about the prisoners, and we head to the next station.
杰瑞说，当他刚到巴格达时，殴打在监狱里很常见，食物也不够。如果家人给你带食物，很好。如果不带，那就太糟了。他说，现在巴格达监狱每天提供两顿饭，达到了红十字会的标准。过度拥挤仍然是个问题，有时超过100人挤进只能容纳50人的房间。杰瑞与指挥官罗德将军（General Rod）核实，商讨囚犯问题，然后我们前往下一个站点。
So how did that inspection go? How do you think that station's doing?
那次视察进行得如何？你认为那个站点做得怎么样？
I think it's doing very well. The prisoner count is down. The prisoner conditions are not as bad as they were. Station's cleaner. There seemed to be a patrol returning when we were leaving, there was a group of IPs coming back in--
我认为做得很好。囚犯人数减少了。囚犯的条件不像以前那么差了。站点更干净了。我们离开时似乎有一支巡逻队正在返回，有一群 IP（伊拉克警察）回来了——
IPs, Iraqi police.
IP，伊拉克警察。
--coming back in, that seemed to be coming back in off patrol or prisoner transport, perhaps. Under the previous regime, under Saddam's regime, they were discouraged, actively discouraged, from doing proactive policing, from getting out on the street. And the police did not do much in the way of investigations. They had no training, very little experience at it.
——回来了，看起来可能是结束巡逻或囚犯押送。在前政权下，在萨达姆政权下，他们是被阻止的，积极地阻止做主动的警务工作，阻止走上街头。而且警察在调查方面做得不多。他们没有训练，几乎没有相关经验。
A couple of bombings, the Jordanian embassy, the UN bombing, even the bombing at our hotel, when the police arrived at the scene of these bombings, they pretty much didn't know what to, except pick up the injured people, and then stand around. They had no sense of forensic investigations.
几次爆炸，约旦大使馆、联合国爆炸案，甚至我们酒店的爆炸案，当警察到达这些爆炸现场时，他们几乎什么都不知道该怎么做，除了捡起伤员，然后站在一边。他们对法医调查毫无概念。
There's more. Iraqi cops would never get weapons training under Saddam Hussein. They'd just get a weapon. No target practice. So they don't know how to shoot. Corruption was endemic, and many older cops see no reason to change.
还有更多。伊拉克警察在萨达姆·侯赛因统治下从未接受过武器训练。他们只会得到武器。没有靶场练习。所以他们不知道怎么开火。腐败是地方病，许多老警察看不到改变的理由。
Jerry has the tiniest translator possible, with a tiny voice. Osma is 27, but can, and sometimes does, pass herself off as a teenager. She has long, straight brown hair, a small face, and is draped in what looks like a massive, sleeveless shawl, but is, in fact, Jerry's special lightweight bulletproof vest from home. He had it sent over for her. She's too small to support the weight of a regular vest.
杰瑞有个声音极小的翻译。奥斯玛（Osma）27岁，但可以，有时也确实以青少年自居。她留着长长的直棕色头发，小脸，披着看起来像是一件巨大的无袖披肩，但实际上是杰瑞从家带来的特殊轻量级防弹背心。他是为她寄过来的。她太小了，无法承受普通背心的重量。
They have a routine. Jerry keeps trying to set her up with his driver, [? Hatten. ?] She amuses herself by making up stories that she tries to convince Jerry are true. For instance, an April fool's joke she played on him, which Jerry explains, with Osma shaking her head and correcting him.
他们有套常规流程。杰瑞一直试图撮合她和他的司机哈顿（Hatten）。她通过编造一些她试图让杰瑞相信是真的故事来自娱自乐。例如，她和他开的一个愚人节玩笑，杰瑞解释说，奥斯玛摇着头纠正他。
She told me that she got engaged to someone she did not know, that her family had arranged the engagement, and that she was going to be leaving Iraq. I called her bluff on their engagement.
她告诉我她和一个她不认识的人订婚了，她的家人安排了这场订婚，她将要离开伊拉克。我拆穿了她关于订婚的谎言。
You knew that it was a lie?
你知道那是谎言？
Yeah.
是的。
No, no.
不，不。
Of course I did, you're always--
我当然知道，你总是——
I swear, Abu Matthew.
我发誓，阿布·马修（Abu Matthew）。
Osma calls him Abu Matthew, father of Matthew, his son's name. It's a term of respect and endearment.
奥斯玛叫他“阿布·马修”，马修的父亲，这是他儿子的名字。这是一个表示尊重和亲切的称呼。
This is not testimony.
这不是证词。
It's not testimony? I knew you were lying.
不是证词？我知道你在撒谎。
No, you didn't.
不，你不知道。
Because you would not go in to an arranged marriage. You told me you would not let your mother and father pick your husband.
因为你不会去接受包办婚姻。你告诉过我你不会让你的母亲和父亲挑选你的丈夫。
But, Iraq is going to be changed.
但是，伊拉克将会改变。
You told me that you would not do that.
你告诉过我你不会那样做。
I will be changed as Iraq will be. The whole country will be changed, so you don't think I am going to change my mind?
我会改变，就像伊拉克会改变一样。整个国家都会改变，所以你不觉得我会改变主意吗？
I just don't think you would let your mother and father pick your husband for you.
我只是不觉得你会让你的母亲和父亲为你挑选丈夫。
This is a new democracy.
这是一个新的民主国家。
She has freedom now to do whatever she wants to do.
她现在有自由做她想做的任何事。
Yeah. This is a new Iraq.
是的。这是一个新伊拉克。
This is the idea of democracy as it's filtered down to the street, Osma said. Iraqis doing things they know probably aren't right, like driving down the wrong side of the highway, for instance, and saying, well, this is democracy, this is freedom.
这就是民主思想传达到街头的方式，奥斯玛说。伊拉克人做着他们知道可能不对的事情，例如在高速公路反方向驾驶，然后说：“好吧，这是民主，这是自由。”
[MILITARY COMMAND]
（军事指令）
[DRUMROLL]
（鼓声）
It's graduation day for the first batch of Iraqi police recruits to complete the new eight-week training program at the police academy in Baghdad. Almost 500 men and a few women in bright blue shirts and navy pants. They're heading into the most dangerous job an Iraqi can have, Jerry says. Nearly 500 Iraqi police have been killed in attacks by insurgents since the war ended. Two officers Jerry knew, leaders in reforming the police, were murdered.
这是首批在巴格达警察学院完成8周新培训项目的伊拉克警察新兵的毕业日。将近500名男性和几名女性穿着明亮的蓝色衬衫和海军蓝裤子。杰瑞说，他们正走向伊拉克人能从事的最危险的工作。自战争结束以来，近500名伊拉克警察在叛乱分子的袭击中丧生。杰瑞认识的两名警察，警察改革的领导者，被谋杀了。
Some police officers have joined the insurgents. Some refuse to fight them. One tried to suicide-bomb the chief of police. The recruits march around, then stop and stand at attention in front of a raised platform with a canopy over it, where Iraqi and American dignitaries are sitting. Jerry is up there, also Paul Bremer, who gives a speech that's translated into Arabic as he goes along. He starts out with the Arabic greeting, peace be upon you.
一些警察加入了叛乱分子。一些拒绝与他们作战。一个人试图自杀式炸弹袭击警察局长。新兵们列队行进，然后停下并在一个带有顶棚的高台前立正，伊拉克和美国显要人物坐在上面。杰瑞就在那里，还有保罗·布雷默（Paul Bremer），他发表了一篇演讲，翻译成阿拉伯语。他以阿拉伯语的问候“和平与你们同在”开始。
The men and women who are standing before us today are the line between civilization and barbarism.
今天站在我们面前的男女是文明与野蛮之间的防线。
Bremer is delivering this speech the day after the killing and mutilation of the four private security guys in Fallujah. He has to address this, and he does, over and over again.
布雷默是在费卢杰四名私人安保人员被杀害和肢解的第二天发表这篇演讲的。他必须处理这件事，他做到了，一遍又一遍。
Yesterday's events in Fallujah are a dramatic example of the ongoing struggle between human dignity and barbarism, that have put to shame the human jackals who defiled the streets of Fallujah. The cowards and ghouls who acted yesterday represent the worst of society.
费卢杰昨日发生的事件是人类尊严与野蛮行为之间持续斗争的一个戏剧性例子，让那些亵渎费卢杰街头的人类豺狼感到羞耻。昨天行事的懦夫和食尸鬼代表了社会中最坏的部分。
The central idea of the speech, that the people who mutilated the bodies of four Americans in Fallujah represent the worst of Iraq, and you, the new police recruits, represent the best, isn't a bad point. But by framing every compliment as a contrast to Fallujah, and by never mentioning how big a risk these recruits are taking by putting on police uniforms, Bremer makes clear he's speaking more to the home audience, to the cameras that will replay clips in America, than he is to the people standing in front of him.
演讲的核心思想是，那些在费卢杰肢解四名美国人尸体的人代表了伊拉克最坏的部分，而你们，新的警察新兵，代表了最好的部分，这一点说得不错。但通过将每一次赞美都与费卢杰进行对比，且从不提及这些新兵穿上警察制服承担了多大的风险，布雷默清楚地表明他说话的对象更多是国内观众，是对准那些将在美国播放视频片段的摄像机，而不是站在他面前的人。
Taxpayers of the United States are providing almost $19 billion for the reconstruction of Iraq. We are spending billions of dollars to create--
美国纳税人正在为伊拉克的重建提供近190亿美元。我们正在花费数十亿美元来创建——
The Marshall plan for Europe, George Marshall started writing that in 1942, even before we knew we were going to win the war in Europe. He was prepared for the reconstruction of Germany. So we didn't have that detailed a plan for the reconstruction of Iraq.
乔治·马歇尔（George Marshall）在1942年就开始写欧洲的马歇尔计划了，甚至在我们知道我们将赢得欧洲战争之前。他为德国的重建做了准备。所以我们没有为伊拉克的重建制定那么详细的计划。
Jerry is frustrated at the pace of reconstruction, both overall and in the police system. It took six months to get the Coalition Provisional Authority to buy guns and bulletproof vests for Iraqi police, he says. Not enough Americans were brought in to work with the new cops. And there's still a lot of corruption among the old cops, not just bribery, but cases of rape, murder, and kidnapping. Just last month, shots were fired at his translator Osma's house. Rather than take it to the police, she decided to resolve it with a tribal mediator, which even Jerry thought would be more effective.
杰瑞对重建的步伐感到沮丧，无论是整体还是警察系统。他说，花了六个月时间才让联盟临时管理当局为伊拉克警察购买武器和防弹背心。没有带进足够的美国人与新警察合作。而且老警察中仍然存在大量腐败，不仅仅是贿赂，还有强奸、谋杀和绑架案件。就在上个月，有人向他的翻译奥斯玛的房子开枪。她决定不找警察，而是决定用部落调解人解决，连杰瑞都认为这会更有效。
How's it going, men? It's a great day to be an American. I'm going to shoot some weapons.
进行得怎么样，伙计们？今天真是做美国人的好日子。我要去射击一些武器。
The last day I spent with Hank, the Custer Battles guy from the first half of the show, we pulled up to a soldier who was guarding the entrance to a shooting range where Hank and the Custer Battles guys were heading to get some target practice. Just before we stopped to get out, Hank said--
我和节目上半部分的卡斯特-巴特尔员工汉克待在一起的最后一天，我们将车开到一个士兵面前，他守卫着一个射击场的入口，汉克和卡斯特-巴特尔的家伙们正前往那里进行靶场练习。在我们停下来准备下车之前，汉克说——
We are the frontier freedom. We are the centurions that stand post on the long frontier of freedom.
我们是边疆的自由。我们是站在自由漫长边疆上的百夫长。
This ended up being the theme of the morning, though it's the kind of thing Hanks says all the time.
这成了那天上午的主题，尽管这是汉克经常说的那种话。
Once again, in this small perimeter, freedom has been advanced. You can smell it, can't you? Right here. If nothing else, our time together, Nancy, you should learn to smell the freedom. Freedom is the smell of good loads that have just gone down range, the wafting of a powder burned in the cause, a noble cause.
再一次，在这个小小的周边范围内，自由得到了推进。你能闻到它，不是吗？就在这里。如果说还有什么的话，我们在一起的时间，南希，你应该学会闻一闻自由的味道。自由是那些刚射击出去的装药的味道，是为了一个高尚事业燃烧火药的气味。
There was a question I'd been trying to ask Hank the whole time I spent in Iraq about exactly this, the frontier of freedom, and his relationship to it. But I could never quite get it right, so I tried once more. And the question amounted to, do you ever have doubts about what you're doing here?
我在伊拉克一直试图问汉克一个问题，关于这正是“自由边疆”，以及他与它的关系。但我总是无法准确表达，所以我又试了一次。这个问题大致是：你有没有怀疑过你在这里做的事情？
I mean, a soldier's got a pretty perfect world, because he just takes his orders. And at the end of the day, you just say, maybe, maybe they were a little crazy with that order, but I did my part. You know, I held the barricade.
我的意思是，士兵们有一个非常完美的世界，因为他们只是执行命令。到最后，你只会说：“也许，也许他们的命令有点疯狂，但我尽了我的职责。”你知道，我守住了路障。
Right, but that's, I mean, that's soldiers, and that's being in the army. And you're not in the army anymore. You're a civilian in a democracy. Don't you have questions along those lines?
没错，但那是，我的意思是，那是士兵，那是身处军队。你已经不在军队里了。你是一个民主国家的平民。你难道没有类似的问题吗？
Well, not right now, because I'm actually kind of back right now.
嗯，现在没有，因为我现在实际上有点回到那种状态了。
Back in a military mindset.
回到了军事思维状态。
Yeah. But yeah, on a daily basis. I've got a son that's in the army. So you sit back at a TV screen when you're not here, and you're going, God, I hope they know what the hell they're doing when they send my kid in harm's way. And the sad part is, you spend your whole life with a kid protecting him, keeping him out of the street. Get out of the street! Put on your bicycle helmet. What are you doing? Then, next thing you know, you're watching him deploy to combat. You're going, God, what have I done?
是的。但确实，在日常生活中。我有个儿子在军队。所以当你不在的时候，你坐在电视屏幕前，你会说：“上帝，我希望他们派我孩子去危险的地方时知道自己在搞什么。”可悲的是，你花了一辈子保护一个孩子，让他远离街道。“离开街道！戴上你的自行车头盔。你在干什么？”然后，接下来你所知道的，就是看着他部署去战斗。你会说：“上帝，我都做了些什么？”
So you've got an ambivalence, because he's out in the middle of the street. And you just hope, somewhere, that there's some tremendously bright guys that are sitting around a whiteboard and figuring it all out, and they have a plan. Unfortunately, every once in a while you meet one of the guys. And you should say, tell me you're his double.
所以你有矛盾，因为他身处街道中央。你只能希望，在某个地方，有一些极其聪明的人坐在白板前算出了一切，并且他们有一个计划。不幸的是，每隔一段时间你就会遇到其中一个人。你应该说：“告诉我你只是他的替身。”
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
（侧面交谈）
I'm coming. I've only fired 20 rounds. I'm getting all 20 of those.
我来了。我才开了20发。我要把这20发全打中。
Nancy Updike. Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder.
南希·厄普代克。好了，我们的节目今天由萨拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）、戴安·库克（Diane Cook）、温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）和莉莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。
In the year since today's program was first broadcast, the number of Iraqi police and military killed has climbed from 500, as Nancy said, to at least 2,200. And in fact the real number may be more like 3,000.
在今天节目首次播出的这一年里，阵亡的伊拉克警察和军事人员数量从南希所说的500人攀升到了至少2200人。实际上，真实的数字可能更接近3000人。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
You know, you can download today's program and our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道，你可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载今天的节目和我们的档案。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助方名单）
WBEZ management oversight by Mr. Torey Malatia, who is not afraid of your guff.
WBEZ 的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）负责，他不怕你们的牢骚。
I've RPGs across the roof. I've had 62-millimeter mortar rounds hit in front.
我的车顶上中过 RPG。我的前面落过62毫米迫击炮弹。
Back next week with more stories of this American life.
下周回来，带来更多关于这个美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。